it's always sort of breathtaking
whenever we get a little bit of honesty
out of Planned Parenthood you never
expect it because the abortion industry
runs on lies deception
okay that's their that's their primary
fuel source that and the blood of the
innocent so those two things but every
once in a while every once in a while
someone at Planned Parenthood will kind
of peek up from the muck and the dirt
and the blood and they'll accidentally
say something honest and that's when you
stop and you take note because it's such
a significant moment so that happened
this week
lianna when is the new president of
Planned Parenthood after the most
prolific mass murderer in history Cecile
Richards stepped down lianna when took
her place lianna when goes by dr. Winn
but I'm not gonna call her doctor
because she's a doctor in the same way
that John Wayne Gacy was a clown okay
that's just it's it's it's a cover they
use it's something that they it's a it's
a title that they use to lure their
victims in all right but when was
profiled by BuzzFeed recently and the
BuzzFeed article claims that when wants
to focus on non abortion services she
wants Planned Parenthood to focus on the
non abortion part and kind of highlight
that and do more of that
well when took issue with this and
here's what she tweeted okay she said
this is the president of Planned
Parenthood by the way all right just to
reiterate she said I am always happy to
do interviews but these headlines
completely misconstrue my vision for
Planned Parenthood first our core
mission is providing protecting and
expanding access to abortion and
reproductive health care we will never
back down from that fight it is a
fundamental human right and women's
lives are at stake okay again first our
core mission is providing protecting and
expanding access to abortion core
mission she didn't even say that's one
of our core missions that's that's a
corpsman she said that's our core
mission providing protecting and
expanding access to abortion
now I know that if you don't follow
these things very closely but you you
know you have a general sense of what
Planned Parenthood does you'll hear that
and you'll say yeah
so obviously Planned Parenthood they
that's what they do they do abortions
well yes I know that you know that but
that's not what Planned Parenthood has
been saying about itself for the last 50
years and that's not what Planned
Parenthood's proponents say and those
who are proponents of tax funding for
planned paradise a they have always said
that abortion is just a tiny part of
what they do a tiny almost insignificant
sort of afterthought they've said that
abortion is three percent of their
business that's the number that we've
been hearing over and over again for
decades abortion is 3 percent of our
business now if something is 3 percent
of your business
can you really say that it's your core
mission if a restaurant were to if 3
percent of a restaurants sales were
let's say coffee would it make sense for
them to call themselves a you know a
coffee place and say that their core
mission is selling coffee if that's your
core mission then you're really bad at
it
well the 3% figure was always nonsense
and all you had to do was look at the
look at the numbers they've they've
they've been saying for years that
abortion is 3 percent of their business
yet if you look at the numbers you'll
see that abortion is by far and away the
most significant source of revenue for
them or I should say the most
significant non-governmental source of
revenue because they get five hundred
million dollars a year in tax money so
aside from the tax money that that's
shoveled into their pockets it's they
it's the the number one source of
revenue yet they've been saying for
years that it's only 3 percent number
one source of revenue they say 3 percent
how did they how did they say how did
they come up with that number how did
they get away with it well partly it's
just a bald-faced lie but then also
partly here's what they would this is
what
they would do they would um they would
they would call it uh they would
unbundle their services that's sort of
the phrase that would be used and what
that means is that for instance if a if
a woman came in got an abortion paid
three four hundred bucks for it or more
and then on the way out the door was
handed a little bit of free birth
control they would put that down in the
books as to services provided and they
would count them equally even though the
main point of the visit was the abortion
and that's where all the money came from
and that's the thing that was paid for
because she got the the birth control on
the way out they call it - services
provided so that would be as if let's
say there was a car dealership and you
were to go in buy a car for $32,000 but
while you're you know waiting there and
maybe the the the guy is going to get
some paperwork for you to fill out so
you go and you run to the to the vending
machine real quick and get yourself a
Pepsi so you buy a Pepsi and you buy a
car and that would be like if the if the
car dealership were to write that down
in the books as to services provided and
count them equally as if they're exactly
the same thing as if you came there for
the Pepsi and the car and as far as the
car dealership is concerned they're both
as significant as you know that they are
the purchases are equal in significance
in their minds that that's what it's
like and then the car dealership can you
know look at their books at the end of
the day and say look we sold five cars
and we sold five Pepsi's so selling
Pepsi is 50% of our business doesn't
make any sense
and now it seems that after all these
years after saying three percent of our
business three percent of our business
three percent of our business now
finally they're admitting that it was
all a lie fifty years of a lie just
exposed by Planned Parenthood just
admitted you know
me of the time at a National Abortion
Federation conference and this was video
that got very little attention from
anyone but Lisa Harris is the director
or was anyway a few years ago the
director of Planned Parenthood of
Planned Parenthood of Michigan and she
was caught in an undercover video saying
to a crowd of people at a National
Abortion Federation conference this is
what she said she's talking about what
points can be conceded to pro lifers and
this is what she says she says given
that we actually see the fetus the same
way and given that we might actually
both agree that there's violence in here
let's just give them all the violence
it's a person it's killing let's just
give them that this again director of
Planned Parenthood of Michigan speaking
at a panel at a National Abortion
Federation conference and she says it's
a person it's killing those are two
things again that a Planned Parenthood
would never admit publicly it's a person
and it's killing yet when you get them
behind closed doors and they think that
nobody else is listening they're going
to admit well yeah of course it's a
person that we're killing now everybody
invite all the all the so-called doctors
and everybody in you know people who
work for Planned part they all know what
they're doing this whole idea that it's
not killing a person that's just the
stupidity that they that they feed to
the to the lemmings in the public and
then they in and they say sit back and
almost scratch their heads like how are
these people buying this obviously we're
killing a person that's the whole point
of the procedure it is specifically
designed to kill somebody if there was
no person to kill there be no ryu and
become an inferno abortion but and
case at least that's something that was
admitted behind closed doors as I said
when they thought nobody else was
listening in the case of Liana when
she's just coming out and saying yeah
this is this is what we do we provide
abortions that's our thing it's our core
mission so then the question is and I
raised this question yet again I don't
know why I keep bringing it up you know
but it will this finally lead to the
defunding of Planned Parenthood I mean
can this finally be the thing now that
you've got the president of Planned
Parenthood saying this is our core
mission is to provide abortions and
we're giving them five hundred million
dollars a year in tax money can this be
the thing that the funds Planned
Parenthood well no no of course not of
course not now especially because the
Republicans controlled Congress and the
White House for two years that was their
time to do it oh they can't remember
when when when Barack Obama was was
present for eight years Republicans
really wanted to defund Planned
Parenthood and they came up with all
these different bills that would defund
Planned Parenthood and they said oh you
know I we really want to do it but we've
got bombers they're just gonna veto it
oh shoot there's I mean we'd love to we
just can't and then Donald Trump gets
into the White House and they control
Congress and somehow this issue that
they supposedly cared about for eight
years and really wanted to do just slips
their mind for two years and here's what
I'm guessing that now that Democrats
control the House Republicans are all of
a sudden going to rediscover their
passion for defunding Planned Parenthood
now they're gonna decide that oh yeah
well what was that thing we wanted to do
oh yeah the fund Planned Parenthood hey
guys let's do that oh we can't now
because the Democrats control house oh
man we missed it again absolute cowards
cowards and Liars that is that's
basically the story of of abortion and
how abortion has remained legal all
these years and how Planned Parenthood
has remained funded all these years
okay let's get to some karmic news
Starbucks you may recall the great
bathroom outrage at Starbucks of course
there are so many contrived outrages in
a year that it's hard to keep track of
all of them but this one was so phony
and so divorced from anything resembling
reality that it's really worth keeping
in mind it's it's one that's that I've
remembered maybe you have as well but if
you haven't just a quick refresher
course this was back in April or May of
last year a Starbucks manager at a
location in Philadelphia became the
target of the pitchfork Brigade after
refusing restroom privileges to a couple
of people who came in wanting to use the
restroom the only problem was that the
people who came in were not customers
and they weren't buying anything and so
the two men who happened to be black
we're told that well if you want to use
the restroom you have to buy something
hey good news you can buy a coffee here
for like two bucks or you could buy a
bottle of water I mean you could buy
anything and you're a customer just like
that and now you can use the bathroom
but they were they decided that they
didn't want to use the bathroom so they
they didn't want to buy anything so they
couldn't they couldn't use the bathroom
this was not a policy that this manager
invented on her own this was a corporate
policy at Starbucks at the time and this
is also a policy that many restaurants
and stores enforce especially in urban
areas because you've got a lot of people
coming in it's it's very jammed very
crowded and so they need to make sure
that the people that are taking up
tables and using the facilities are
actually customers so the men sat down
at a table after you know after asking
to use a restroom being told only
customers can use harassment declining
to buy something they then went and sat
down at a table while still refusing to
purchase something and so the manager
goes over after they've just called
attention to themselves like that now
she knows that they're they're not
buying an
think taking up a table again this is a
busy Starbucks it's not fair to take up
a table like if you've ever if you ever
been into a Starbucks before you know
that tables can be hard to come by and
so if you have your coffee and your
little Danish or whatever that you
bought and you can't sit down because
there are two guys taking up a table who
didn't even buy anything that's not fair
it doesn't make any sense for a store to
allow that so she goes over to them and
she says hey guys if you want to sit at
a table
you got to buy something and then this
is this was that the context that came
out later she off she offered to serve
them right there at the table like she
was a waitress she said I'll get you I
get you a coffee can I get you something
and they still refuse to buy anything
and finally after refusing the the
police were called because they were
trespassing and the two guys were taken
out in cuffs as they deserve to be
because if you are trespassing like that
and you're not following the rules of
the establishment and you're taking up
space without buying something and
you're asked to leave and you refuse you
deserve to be hauled out in handcuffs
but of course racism was immediately
assumed despite a total lack of evidence
to support the charge and the racism
charge was especially idiotic number one
because the woman was simply following
corporate policy number two because it's
a starbucks in philadelphia presumably
black people come into that store all
the time presumably this manager has
interacted with and served black
customers doesn't hundreds of times
without any incident so now if you could
if anyone could have ever come up with
evidence that she on a regular basis
would kick out black customers for no
reason well then maybe now you have a
reason to suspect that there's racism
involved but if hundreds of black
customers have come in and out and she
has served them and there's been no
incident and all of a sudden there's an
incident with these two particular guys
it doesn't make any sense whatsoever to
assume that race had anything to do with
it at all
nevertheless the Starbucks CEO publicly
through this loyal
employee under the bus and finally in
their last act of corporate cowardice
Starbucks reversed their restaurant
policy and made a big show of announcing
that now anybody can come in sit at the
tables use the bathroom you don't have
to be a customer it doesn't matter all
right so that's the background right
just to refresh your memories
fast-forward a few months and here we
are and now it's it has been reported
that certain Starbucks locations less
than a year after announcing this
enlightened new bathroom policy now are
going to be installing special
disposable boxes for used heroin needles
in their bathrooms okay they're also
going to be removing trash cans from
some of their bathrooms because the
employees have expressed concern about
getting pricked with needles when they
change out the trash bags there have
been reports of condoms alcohol bottles
bloodstains on the floors and on the and
on the walls ironically this this free
bathroom policy this bathroom
free-for-all has made the bathrooms less
accessible there was a report in The New
York Post
a few weeks ago about some Starbucks in
New York where you can't use any
bathroom because the stalls are closed
for extended periods of time due to the
New York Post says prolonged cleaning
efforts you got to wonder what's going
on in those bathrooms if they have to be
shut for days to be cleaned now it could
be pointed out that Starbucks probably
had many of these problems before the
the new policy so it's not like these
problems just started now yeah fine
that's exactly the point that's why the
policy existed in the first place that's
why stores and restaurants have policies
like this and that's why these policies
are especially enforced
in urban areas because a it's just a
fact of a matter that a spacious private
sting single stall bathroom at a place
like Starbucks in an urban area is a
very attractive place for drug addicts
and drunks and vagrants and other
assorted characters most businesses
though are not interested in becoming de
facto homeless shelters or de facto
halfway homes it's just that's not the
Starbucks is in the business of selling
coffee they're not in the business of
providing or at least they didn't used
to be in the business of providing safe
spaces for heroin addicts to shoot up
heroin you know and historically that's
why they reserve their bathrooms and
their tables for people who are actually
interested in purchasing a product now
that's not a it's not a fail proof plan
just because you have that policy
doesn't mean you're necessarily going to
be stopped gonna be able to stop
everyone from going into the bathroom to
get high or drink or you know engage in
other sorts of activities messy
activities but it's still relatively
effective it's a relatively effective
way to stop that stuff from happening in
your bathrooms there's a reason why the
stores now or some stores now need
needle disposal boxes and that only
became necessary after they changed the
policy so Starbucks
Changez this bathroom policy says okay
anyone can come in even if you're not a
customer and now they need special boxes
to dispose of heroin needles what does
that teach us so what what have we
learned here is the question now it's
likely that the people at corporate
Starbucks have learned precisely nothing
at all but the rest of us I think maybe
have discovered yet again that caving to
the unthinking outraged masses will
profit you nothing in the end there's no
reason to do it because if you abandon a
thoughtful well reasoned path if you
have a a reasonable policy that you give
up on that you abandon just because some
imbeciles are shouting words at you that
end with issed or phobic you are going
to end up paying a much higher price
than the price that the imbeciles may
have been able to extract if you had not
caved to them and in Starbucks in the
case of Starbucks you're gonna wind up
shamed and embarrassed with bloodstains
on your floor and heroin needles in your
trashcan
but at least nobody will call you a
racist
I guess that is until they come back and
think of another reason to call you a
racist who knows maybe the heroin
disposal boxes maybe those are racist
too maybe next we'll have the the
outraged mob saying no you know what
heroin addicts they have every right to
leave their needles wherever they want
how dare you if a heroin addict wants to
come into your bathroom and leave a
needle just sitting there on the ground
that is his god-given right and it is it
is elitist and classist and racist and
sexist somehow for you to for you to
provide these boxes for people these
shameful boxes that exclude and other
eyes and make them feel less than other
people you know who knows maybe that
maybe that'll be the next argument
because it never
once you start caving to them it never
ends they're gonna keep coming back and
back and back and there's never an end
to it
finally last thing today quickly I
thought this was worth mentioning
tipping flight attendants that is the
newest trend apparently and it's mainly
one airline Frontier Airlines that's on
the forefront here they will now give
you the option so generous they've given
you this option too to tip your flight
attendant yeah
no no way look I'm a proponent of
tipping okay I like to think of myself
as a good tipper tip the waitress tip
the pizza delivery guy tip housekeeping
at a hotel tip your uber driver I'm all
about that fine but the main thing with
all of these different people who you
tip is that number one they are
low-paying jobs where the tips account
for a large percentage of their overall
income being a flight attendant is not
really a low paying job I think the
average income for a flight attendant is
fifty or fifty-five thousand dollars a
year also these people they can really
make your customer service experience
negative or positive depending on how
well you tip so there's an incentive you
know it's a bit of a quid pro quo thing
there's an incentive to if you tip them
then it kind of greases the wheels and
it makes thing things run easier for you
when I delivered pizzas and this is just
something that you should know I mean
it's it's it should be obvious but just
so you know this is the way it works
with with pizza delivery I deliver
pizzas for a little bit and you better
believe that I remembered who the non
tippers were I mean that that stuck out
to me and we're still the people who tip
like a quarter somehow there's just
something about it but people who tip
nothing they were bad but somehow even
worse than that were the people who like
if the if the total was 1987
they'll give
20 and say keep the change as if is if
they're doing doing you a big favor keep
the change
oh thank you 13 cents that's my tip
thank you so much I would rather that
you demand exact change back which
actually had the guy do that once he
demanded exact change I didn't have it
so he demanded that I go back to the
store to get him his exact change and
then bring it back to him which I did
because I had no choice but then I made
sure and I let everybody in the store
know this guy is a huge jerk and so if
he orders a pizza and it happens to show
up four hours late I mean you know it
happens and so I would keep I would keep
track of that and I made sure that if
you tipped well I'm ensure that your
order was right I made sure the pizza
got to you soon and who knows sometimes
I might I might accidentally bring you
an extra back of box of chicken wings or
something you know you scratch my back I
scratch yours it's that kind of thing
bad tippers are always punished good
tippers are rewarding but in air an
airline is a totally different thing and
airplanes a totally different thing
mainly because airlines think of new
ways to make the experience more
miserable and more expensive every year
you know they get together and they say
well you know it seems like our
customers aren't broke and miserable
enough so how can we solve that problem
and someone says oh I know what we
should do let's remove legroom
altogether and then you have to pay a
twenty two hundred ninety nine dollar up
charge if you want the privilege of
having blood circulate through your legs
during the trip and so that you know
they're doing that kind of stuff every
year and it just removes any incentive
to tip in my mind it's expensive enough
as it is
besides I don't really need the flight
attendant to do anything for me on the
flight I bring my own snacks I bring my
own drink I already know that the seat
cushion is a flotation device you don't
need to tell me that every single time
and you know it's great to know that by
the way because if the plane happens to
crash into the ocean it'll be good to
know that my mangled bloodied dead
carcass can float on the cushion for a
while before it's consumed by sharks so
that's nice but other than that I don't
really need the flight attendant to do
anything for me thus the incentive to
tip is Eve
unless I don't know what do you think
though should-should flight attendants
be added into the category of customer
service people that we tip I'm saying no
but who knows maybe I'm wrong it happens
every once in a while that I'm wrong
though rarely all right we'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed